don't you heard we're opening up America
again
President Trump gave States guidelines
to start easing lock down restrictions
and the medical experts are on board
it's a three phase process that starts
once a region sees a downward trend in
koban 19 cases for two weeks phase one
still gotta avoid groups of more than
ten restaurants gyms and places of
worship can open with social distancing
guidelines and you can finally have that
elective surgery but implants here I
come but that's a good thing and of
course those at risk need to stay home
also good phase to avoid groups of fifty
or more schools can reopen bars can
reopen with diminished occupancy sounds
like me and not essential travel can
resume phase three four states with no
signs of a coronavirus rebound
workplaces can resume with unrestricted
staffing and visits to hospitals and
senior living facilities can resume so
of these fairly specific guidelines what
did Nancy Pelosi call them vague and
inconsistent but how dialed in is she
really let's check in with the
butt-kisser to the stars James Corden
what are you going to share with us from
your home chocolate really chocolate
chocolate candy oh wow and this is this
is something you can get through the
mail okay yeah absolutely this is the
episode of cribs I never knew I needed
oh wow other people in our family look
for some other flavors but chocolate and
then we have some other chocolate here
nan nan you've offered no practical
advice preferring to snipe and now
you're showing off your double-wide
freezers stocked with enough ice cream
to feed Guam I have a rule the more
removed you are from the consequences of
a calamity the less you matter in
discussing that clip calamity so sit
this one out Nancy and keep stuffing
your frozen face with frozen yogurt
meanwhile of the guidelines
Biden said this well I wouldn't call it
a plan I think what he's done he's kind
of punted he's decided that he's not he
doesn't have the right to make the call
for the country and he's talks about
phases that in a generic sense seemed to
me from all I've learned and all I've
listened and my morning briefs from the
docs I talked to is not it's not
irrational but it doesn't give you any
hard guidelines what the hell is he
talking about
first if Trump decided to call the shots
Joe would have called him a dictator a
tyrant
so now Trump offers a framework that
lets governors make the call
and now he's punting I'd say Joe is
playing politics but in his head he's
probably playing Yahtzee
maybe he should join Nancy's ice cream
in the freezer God knows there's room
but as this surreal moment in time
continues so do you for now there are
stresses and they're starting to show
I'm not gonna lie it's been a strain on
relationships
this was my wife and I before the
quarantine and this is us now
yep it's getting to everyone and
creating a world of disturbing mysteries
like who is the person in Tanny town
maryland getting his mail in his
underwear in this newfound era of stay
home save lives comes this Facebook post
from Taneytown police which reads please
remember to put pants on before leaving
the house to check your mail ba yeah
actually I know a friend that used to do
that and he was in Taneytown
it's funny how a Mexico underwear is
have a good old day it's really nice hey
you got for the breeze somehow you know
it's good advice to put pants on before
leaving the house and not just in
shutdowns but I gotta wonder who could
they be referring to hmm
look you know I get it
no job no schedule TV on all day it's
like being Dana's dog in Michigan you
saw a massive protest against the
governor who said you couldn't buy
gardening seeds gardening seeds if
that's not micro micromanaging what is
seeds seems like an essential thing at a
pandemic no unlike clueless politicians
so naturally people like what the hell
see we will trust our leaders until they
push their luck and then we get pissed
seeds are no seeds so right now we're
looking at a pretty calm cool and
collected America but it could be like
those fake sets on old TV westerns and
what you find behind the calm facade is
unrest without pants I have a theory
that we're all telepathic that you and I
at times know exactly what both of us
are thinking because we are thinking the
same thing you know what I mean right
see you do let's say you and I are in a
bar and some dude shows up with a snake
in a tutu you and I don't need to say a
thing we know without making eye contact
this place is great this telepathy
telepathy also happens on Oscar night
into the third hour of this using wound
of entertainment the entire country
knows it's time to turn it off and we do
without even talking to each other we
are like a boy band NSYNC we are a
connected brain not separate identities
races or genders our humanity unites us
and tells us when we are ready and now
it feels like we are ready maybe to go
back to work in phases I think it's week
five and we're patient we're patriotic
but you know and I know that there's
gonna be a limit we're adults we did the
heroic thing but now we have to do the
realistic thing which is weighing the
risks of future behavior we can't be
shut down forever we sacrificed a lot to
protect the vulnerable
and we still will do that but as the
unemployment rate inches closer to
horrifying we got to ask how much more
can we take
meanwhile what's Adam Schiff doing
remember the guy who was always trying
to catch up with his eyeballs
he says his House Intelligence Committee
is conducting real-time oversight of
Trump's coronavirus response but from
home so the guy who captured all the
attention with no win impeachment porn
causing the media to miss this outbreak
is now trying to do it again man you can
imagine what he's really doing at home
and now Adam shifts quarantined video
diary remember clean hands very
important
always remember where your masks I
myself like to go with the triple
protection come and get me Corona I
think it's time to flatten some curves
of my own make it burn
remember your social distancing keeps 6
feet away at all times
Junior that Wilson get away oh I miss
him the other news Trump announced that
we're pulling funding from the abysmal
inept World Health Organization and
whose side did these sheep take this is
an attempt by the president to steer you
away from his own actions if you go
through the scapegoats that he's blamed
so far for this coronavirus pandemic the
WHL members of the news media Democrats
in Congress what you're seeing is a
president who deflects demeans and
denounces others as opposed to taking
responsibility
it's amazing how every day to the media
is still the first day of Trump's
presidency they refused to see that
Trump's just initiating a process he's
done a million times forcing an entity
to do a better job or else show the guy
attire and he's gonna kick it unlike the
media he understands incentives and
persuasion he's the adult in the room
the media the children who see tough
decisions as scary and mean I don't
think they're gonna get through this but
you will the economy is gonna return and
you're going to exit this strange
surreal moment in time smarter wiser
stronger we did the right thing we
sacrificed a lot but maybe it's time for
some of us to get back to work if we
don't we're all screwed it won't be the
proverbial light switch it's more like a
fancy light
dimmer but you don't have to listen to
me it's okay because I'm listening to
you and I hear what you're saying it's
almost like we're thinking the same
thoughts